a nationwide manhunt is underway for two
Georgia inmates accused of shooting and
killing two correctional officers Rickey
DuBose and Donnie Russell Rowe escaped
yesterday morning investigators said
they killed two guards on a prison bus
mark Strassmann is outside the sheriff's
office in Eatonton Georgia mark good
morning good morning the reward is now
up to $75,000 for information that leads
to the arrest of these escapees these
are violent convicted felons who are
armed and in the words of the local
sheriff beyond dangerous Scimitar this
year's have escaped teams of federal
state and local law enforcement searched
into the night for 24 year old Ricky
DuBose and 43 year-old Donnie Russell
Roe the pair were among 33 inmates
riding on this prisoner transport bus
Tuesday morning at 6:45 about 70 miles
southeast of Atlanta investigators say
DuBose and Rowe managed to get past the
cage separating the inmates from the two
guards riding up front 42 year old
sergeant Christopher Monica and 58 year
old sergeant Curtis Beaulieu two of the
prisoners overpowered the guards the
officers who were driving the bus
obtained their weapons and shot and
killed both of the corrections officers
an emotional Putnam County Sheriff
Howard sill said his biggest worry was
the inmates might kill someone else I
saw to brutally murder Krish so that's
what I saw I have the blood on my shoes
SILS says DuBose and roe carjack this
green Honda Civic roughly three hours
later police believe they broke into
this home about 20 miles north where
they stole food and changed clothes we
have located a prison uniform inside the
house he was a very honorable man
Denise blue is Curtis Beaulieu sister we
know that these men will be apprehended
and we know that justice will be served
my brother passed away doing what he
loved
he was a professional in every single
way detectives are questioning the other
inmates on that bus and looking at
onboard surveillance tape but remember
this search going on here the only time
that they have been spotted these
escapees was after they burglarized that
home they were spotted at a local store
but since then nothing Gail
all right thank you mark